yeah hello and welcome to this video
which covers the penultimate round of
this year's Tala steel tournament let's
get going I hope I understand kind of
understandable in a way because my voice
is a little bit off I am handsome
problem yesterday with my throat and
it's not getting any better anyway let's
get going we have a couple of games to
cover and I'm going to start with them I
game that on paper is so most
interesting between the video of the
event where say so with the plus four
score and by eat the tree-sweets Cola is
playing black however and yeah let's see
what happens we're going to check this
game first we've got a Queens gambit and
while you play c5 the semi tirage okay
see takes d5 is to move and now in place
he takes d4 this is a fairly rare
continuation however this is a line that
has been used quite a lot by Chinese
players most prominently value a is a
very strong 2700 player from China and
why he has played this as well in DeWine
the world Rapids so what's the point of
this move well okay why have to take
them on default and if you fatigued with
the night black is going to play Knight
takes d5 and is very largely fine white
has very little to hope for in this
position C and D filer open a black
develops quite quite easily the critical
roof is Queen takes after which black
has a choice the move that has been
played mostly is this however after
night XD 5y probably maintains a small
advantage after you for the move that
the Chinese play is e takes d5 and this
is in fact a pretty interesting line for
black if you're aiming to get to get a
position that is probably going to be a
little bit worse but just a little bit
but has excellent chances of achieving
the draw and why so why is that well if
you look at this with white black is
having this idea 96 attacking the Queen
and how it's like doing direct they're
the only critical who fear is the movie
form if white plays something else let's
say in place g3 as he also does in an IQ
p situation then at 96 and the White
Queen doesn't really have any good place
to go I mean you can go all the way back
but like is even having deform and then
you have to put your knife back to be
wanna this is absolutely awkward so this
is a bit better in comparison but black
is definitely fine in such a situation
yeah this is a lot like reverse see
Theresa selling and where yeah this is
probably equal straight away the only
move is a form to make anything happen
black plays Knight c6 white ghost Bishop
b5 you cannot move the Queen again so we
should be five and now black takes and
this is the thing here why it has no one
decent alternative to the green trade so
we got the can trade 95 and we see that
white is going to get the palm back is
upon down at the moment and ya hear
there's a reverse an option why can also
castle and then take on before maybe
this is the more testing option so
decided to take it can take on these
things and one thing we have to keep in
mind is that he is leading the
tournament have a point ahead of my
youth sell a draw with Wyatt here is
perfectly okay for so in the penultimate
round and well this kind of positions
are with white you can almost never use
legs pawn structure is so bad with those
three pawns in the middle this is all so
weak so black has four isolated pawns in
a wave and
uh why dis just basically I'm okay by
just staying and this is what he did
yeah he didn't do all that much this has
been played before by the way of a
couple of Muslim the company to slay
them and why this is just extremely
solid chance Black has no problems
whatsoever is got this counter play on
their file but why can just draw by
fitting yeah just like shuttle with this
rook let's say or so and this is all
that he has to do in this game so you
had a couple of more moves chan chan
chan chan chan chan chan what opted for
me yeah perpetual of some sort after we
sang so a draw is imminent IAM yeah that
wasn't very exciting you can argue about
blacks approach in this game of course
it's an excellent result anyway for ye
being a solar second um directly behind
so but if you want to win such a super
tournament you need to sometimes take
risks with black maybe he doesn't feel
yet like his legs up for this kind of
thing most players probably would have
done the same thing as ye did here there
are very few players around to actually
willing to risk they are playing for
wing with black in order to win the
tournament they're like quran accountant
also does that um but why he maybe he's
not as well he's relatively new which
was super tournaments we have to see
that he's played only two or three of
all of them um it's a matter how you
count the chinese lanterns anyway so
he's maybe not yet feeling lucky should
risk everything here and played the
super safe opening line that gave him
the drawer basically from the get-go and
the second thing I want to look at is a
little thing as a lot as part of the
game between Hari Krishna and Richard
report and this is coming here yeah h5
honeymoon well why don't threaten in g4
and now well what cannot take here tween
a
for is showing that the H file is is an
icy fo black but our attrition a
tradition of 92 and I think this is an
interesting and interesting position to
look at because it looks like a
completely normal opening position out
of the Carroll advanced but still there
is an opportunity for black that can be
easily missed because we tend to think
in schemes and setups and quite often
not concretely enough here for example
and it would be completely normal
looking for black to play offline
shipments 85 or maybe h4 Bishop e7 maybe
should be seven mile and h1 but like you
have many schematic rules but report
from of the best move taking only five
it traded immediately and maybe he had
spotted the idea before hand so it's a
tactic a little bit out of the blue but
its life takes d4 and two white Bishop
now has nowhere to go to and this
immediately turns the table from ya an
opening position value still arguably
can hope for a wide advantage to
something where black is rather better
because he will get the bishop pair
Bishop has nowhere to go two ND five is
a week this is a nice nice motif but i
also want to show this for one reason
because now Hari Krishna I think there's
a good job of damage control he plays
night before forcing I'm black now to
take only 3 he wants to get the piece
back and you recaptured here only three
with the night with this he is giving up
on the e5 pawn but I think this is still
a good policy from fourth granted
personal takes and now night d3 and with
this move um we are getting into
opposite colors bishops but the night
nice will get again
no as well so how attrition I did a good
damage control job now with the opposite
khalid bishop then black extra porn on
the add file is not not that failed in
the next chocolate mousse receive then
white build up something that has a
fortress type of quality I think blacks
chance is to do something a relatively
low I mean you can try of course and
report and continue this for quite a
while but how attrition I didn't get
into any serious trouble anymore so I
think you did a good damage control Joe
after having missed this this tactic
immediately steering the game into
something that is probably going to be
yeah terrible long run it's not fun but
you get to draw very lightly if you try
something else you're just going to
going to suffer in in the middle game
against the bishop am so a good job by
re Krishna after making this opening
opening this step um okay the next game
we're going to check is the game between
live on aronian at Luke renovating
Aronian only needs to win this game if
he wants to still have a chance at the
top he actually playing a good
tournament we are getting some wins in
and if he now was managed to beat them
the Dutchman is I mean pretty unlucky
and then Lenny would be just have a
point behind Wesley so as we know it
only has drawn in this round so to begin
this lot getting more and more popular
an entire winter outline and when they
actually accepts to get into a king's
indian don't see that too often but he
has done that before in this event and i
am so aronian plays this set up early 93
you don't see this too often normally
white players go for Bishop e3 in this
position or Bishop g5 we should be three
being the most popular I'm 93 is not
seen that often one idea of it could be
that any thief
and b5 move now it can be yeah nicely
taken and white has this open diagonal
now this is probably not going to be a
good kind of Vancouver break we have
been really placed differently 97 and c6
he has done that before this setup okay
Bishop e3 book the age group X 2
interestingly grouping by little bit dog
freeing up the f1 square this is often
an important square to have as black has
ideas like pushing the age porn at the
board and then the night needs a good a
good square and we'll see one looking at
the sea file and now black close this
down and play SC 5 and he basically
allows transposition now into a men-only
structure arguing that his pieces are
not that great like we know 17 and
record the A's and he's got the pollen
before already but at the same time
saying you know you light is also not
that great I have to admit that I have a
strong preference for white in this kind
of situation I think that white is
always going to be better unless he's
doing something something really stupid
you have a better Center you have more
space why shouldn't you be better it's
probably nothing serious but I would
term definitely prefer white in yes we
place is six and get into a modern
benoni structure now with Ian sepan
traded I think this looks nice for white
now he's got the excellent pawn chain
here very safe center the night has a
good idea now to activate itself or in
this case here you haven't really traded
this is not a bad choice by the way you
want to trade some pieces in the penalty
for example if you look at this position
without any minor pieces just imagine
all knights and bishops gone then black
will be okay yeah moves like f5 would be
much more yeah much more interesting and
playable simply because weakening
the king is not such an issue if you
have no minor pieces around it so black
wants to trade some pieces that Bishop
h6 widest unbinding to trade that one as
the bishop is the strongest piece that
black hands preserves it with bishop h
eight and now h three this is a useful
present for later F for Bishop d7 we
should see form which should be five
again trying to trade king h1 and now
why does setting up this this situation
on the King side yeah I think why this a
little bit better it's just easier to
play with all the answer space and you
have more more active idea simply this
pin is really awkward really awkward to
get rid of when very place Queen g7 and
now queen edge form and from here I
think black is losing the friendly
little bit I mean again I have a
preference for watching anyway so it's a
bit difficult to meet you yeah I don't
know I always think that that this is
not a good could not going one good
position anyway even though sometimes it
might be okay and yeah it's like a queen
you five now this is probably not
working they're all that well it's
probably better to take on c4 and
continue from here even though I still
would prefer ydm you have more space and
you have three idea what to do this
wasn't working all that well because of
after luke t 2f form is imminent now the
Queen has no square to go to win it and
Bishop takes you for now maybe it was
better to play 97 get rid of this pin
now for the moment after f4 you can go
here it looks extremely strange this is
what the engine recommends it's probably
probably better with not looking very
human a trait this and we underestimated
the move at four that was very strong
now
just attacking the Queen and yeah now
only event million comes up with a
really young really strong hello maybe
an over reaction of some sort he can
still play Queenie's heaven I mean it's
not much fun but this is the position
that you aim for in a way white is
better after beat eggs or room takes
again with those ideas of playing e5 and
you're not getting rid of this pin
anytime soon what he did is he just said
the Queen when he formed and this is not
yeah not objectively working however and
it demands the precise response and the
only way to refute this completely
completely was Miss now boronia and he
could have just taken here not taking
the Queen and it looks funny but it is
very strong the queen is still hanging
and well no not many squares if you go
here there's f5 and note that this is
essentially a double attack and if you
go here when rookie to and this is very
awkward ninite protects this and where
do you go now this is going to get lost
some places a piece for what so that's
even stronger than what alone Young
plate he took the Queen 90s and will be
one and now with Bishop b5 blacksville
could have we have put up some stiff
resistance I mean I know it's just two
pieces for the Queen but black's pieces
are active now the night is very strong
the bishops are also having good
diagonals the computer finds the way
here for wise that is actually a pretty
nice advantage but it does not feel very
natural and this is clear f5 cheeks and
G floors what the engine suggests and
this is like a bit like lyrical chess
maybe somebody would play that but it
doesn't feel very lot and lot
too obvious to me at all after a form
that the engine wants to sac and play
list this I can't understand I mean the
night was extremely strong and hear what
you would have left and our white
friends to just win the game you have to
take and here wyd retains good control
you're probably going to win this f porn
and down the ideal material of this was
still extremely tough for why to manage
specialty five move but this was played
by them and then really and this is
meeting with a very powerful play now by
Aronian essentially refuting the whole
thing you went at five and there are
things going on all over the place and
this is opening this as well yeah he
took with the bishop on the tulips the
most logical obvious move there and
there's nothing nothing better in it and
now very strong not taking on each arm
but this this is much stronger white
wants to keep this bishop because the
black square is a dark square see I
extremely weakened this is what happens
now very strong play by alone and he
just sex we exchanged in and put the
Queen on f6 black is absolutely helpless
against this Bishop age six and twenty
seven mate okay desperado sec but you
don't have to take DNT event very result
yes absolutely nothing in story against
bishop h6 yeah a nice game Baronia and
some interesting points near the end of
this I really have a bias for whites
position here so don't expect me to be I
mean I don't already don't really see
why this would be an attractive position
for blankets is what is what I think
yeah why does all the ideas and neck is
just sitting there anyway so a good wind
by Iranian it was no harder point behind
the leader Wesley film the final game
I'm going to look at in any
al is to change collagen with black hair
against pas de Leon oflet's or maybe
before that lets ever letsa mention the
other games we also had the game kayak
canoe Komachi that was a completely
uneventful draw the Sicilian re-bond
Giri yeah I drunk I even went for
another into opening like the Vienna or
bishops game and draws a really ancient
theory it was kind of interesting but
giving defended precisely and we got to
draw down and then we had the game were
to shake and Drake him that also was
kind of interesting but yeah again I
wouldn't want to make to our videos and
what the shake had some chances but it
was a it was a tough game running so
let's go from Aronian and I'm sorry
let's go for alien or cows so before by
alien off I note that alien love has a
terrible score against card he's on 0
out of form before this game so default
and carbon goes for the Dutch
interesting and we have to note that
card we need to win here if he wants to
still have a an author of chance to
catch so so f5 and they go for the
Stonewall or carbon goes from the
Stonewall interestingly enough he plays
default immediately and oftentimes it is
said that c6 is the move water of choice
where white waits for white web leg
weights to provide to play the knight to
f3 and only then going try but Carlton
can you just goes d5 now the theoretical
recipes is usually night h3 but I an
offer we have just place neither three
okay so we have the stone ball 93 is not
very common the white set up here
usually white castles and rather
developed the night to d2 or yeah keeps
it on
14 under a while but this is not a bad
setup here this Bishop f4 yes because
the stake in this straight castles III
white is not cancelled yet and now
Karmin slaves the somewhat somewhat
unusual move Bishop d7 it's a little bit
only it's a little bit uncommon to have
this Bishop plate so early you often
want to keep some flexibility with this
piece something that b6 Bishop d7 can
sometimes be energy as well queen bee
three and now car between two c7 yeah 3
p-6 looks a little bit more normal let's
aim but maybe you felt that this is even
less giving him less winning ideas yeah
why would black play such a position by
the way in order to play for win it's an
interesting question I think the main
point is that here in this position you
might be slightly worse but at least you
have a full position like almost all
pieces on the board and they're going to
be some kind of complications of a
strategic or technical nature later so
you're kind of accepting that children's
it worse but you can can hope for a long
game with some complications later
objectively speaking why here is just
better yeah I mean he's got more space
better Bishop and so on the bishop I by
the way is that white has also not that
fantastic but it still has more
long-term prospects and black ones to
memory okay all this looks fairly fairly
normal and now create three an
interesting move by ayan of this idea
offering this via damage of the pawn
structures is quite well known and there
was a game that immediately came to mind
this was also pointed out by my youngest
of fun when he did a video on this game
and at the same thought when I saw it it
was the game with an Allen played in the
2010
championship match against Apollo they
offer the Queen's Rangers like that
allowing the damage of the pawn
structure and yeah black cannot really
avoid the current rate moving it again
would be kinda ridiculous but why does
not unhappy here now it's got to be
found and some ideas a 485 now this
would be quite awkward to face so we
place an 85 something that and now will
be to trying to double yeah again why it
is just more comfortable carbon when 94
and now Elian of took this opportunity
to change the pawn structure it took it
95 yeah it's 60 saying so black has to
play this one and now have three
immediately breaking this up this gives
more scope for the bishop and the knife
also has a good way of coming back into
the game so this position look at seven
my cousin is a good move yeah he needs
to have some protection for the pause
and the look is returning it would be
completely pointless to try something
like that for example answers displacing
this piece for absolutely no reason it
has it has nowhere to go there so look
at seven is good litex to buy an area
north I have to admit that I would have
been very tempted in this position to
play the movie file simply nailing down
the b7 pawn it is a problem um yeah it's
probably slightly good set night f2 but
I still would have been very very
tempted to do it simply to make sure
that this is never going away yeah and
you have a clear pliner you when you
want to go here and potentially going to
e5 you played this first which allowed
the movie 5 this in itself doesn't
really help like on as much as self I
know I probably would have liked to
prevent it but this is not something
that the engine for example
port it seems that why does better here
even then after compared to the set up
with white plains he falsified so what
is why it's going to do 93 oh I'm sorry
now Carla took on the form and plays
Knight to f6 so why is why better in
this position yeah you can compare piece
by piece white Bishop is better than
night is better he's got pressure on the
B file them the only thing that is a
slight weakness stay for porn but that
doesn't really matter all that much now
an early enough probably should have
played the move 95 this is looking very
normal here and now just give up born
like this listen distance he will get
this back and will remain with an
excellent position I mean why there's
just a lot better really hard to say is
cousin would have been able to save this
position really not not not something
you want to be in with black they are
not played this this is not yet a
mistake but I think it gives away a
little bit of ground 94 that's a good
defensive move so is why takes twice the
f4 pawn would hang he played it
correctly click on these six Bishop f4
d5 is also good and now cousin also
plays it correctly Bishop d7 yeah and
now I think why probably should have
played nine to deform the next move only
gives away his advantage 94 still seems
to be bellum even though there are some
extremely um yeah tough lines that are
in store now here white can play like a
normal thinking about about this threat
or you can play welcome to terminals 96
this is an extremely tough thing to do
the idea is that you can actually give
up the full book because this position
is excellent for white this is basically
impossible for a human player to spot
the threat is route takes b7 all stuff
like if the King moves then white can
take can't with win easily in this is a
very very real situation and I mean
nobody basically nobody plays that that
way but you can play 94 now playing
normal move letting 96 the problem is
also black cannot and yeah avoid the
texture as 95 is so awful yeah that was
again a good option for any enough but
he took on your form and this is only
giving away his advantage after pawn
takes yeah black is now having the idea
to take and take on air for I think he's
probably okay now and then the engine
also does so I think in this was the
moment the alien of lost his advantage
you take 95 notes are a mess we should
you fall and now there's noe see the
position has opened up a lot we've got
equal material and the bishop now it's
not a problem please at all it's
actually quite dangerous in some cases
you can imagine the bishop coming he and
like having ideas too late on f1 take 96
look at eight and we see the side angle
III covering their sweat rank and now
i'm like half the first threads look III
is okay b6 and now is losing the thread
completely a d6 if it's not a helpful
move let's say I because this point is
going nowhere he probably miscalculated
something King edge 7 was played and now
I have two three except something like
age 42 was probably still okay but now
Carly could just take the pawn maybe you
overlooked the
yeah actually the Giro can take this is
good for white in fact winning for wine
and the deep bond will promote like it's
not stopping this but black can take
with this and now you're not going to
promote the D porn as Luke the one can
be answered with Google to deform yeah
time travel ok and this was the position
after after the child control and what
is this black is a pawn up this is the
one thing I pranab in a book ending is
not the end of the world often times but
this is a very uncomfortable situation
as white has three split porn he was
pretty easily drawn if he could trade d
and a pawn against legs be and a pawn
but this is difficult to do and it's
tough to say if such an endgame is a
loss or draw on white now it's very
tough the same um if I remember
correctly causal said that he wasn't
entirely sure but he estimated his
winning shot was pretty highly and yeah
probably it's it's something like that
you often say give percentage of a loser
if you would say like eighty percent win
twenty percent draw you're probably not
found in the game and it didn't look
like a lien or had much of a chance to
be honest he managed to trade those
which looks like it proved that progress
but still the problem is that the a porn
is a weakness then here for why Luke t5
is a very good move the ideas that black
wants to do this pressurize this pawn
and maybe try to come around to a three
yeah this is what happened checking the
chant like rook check went over to
pressurize this and now he's combining
the pressure against the
a porn with pressure against the H pond
here and the roof the King actions black
king it's doing stuff here I think it's
a lot and it's also what the engine
confirms can only can't interesting
moment was near the end yeah why does
give an update pawn we couldn't really
hold on to it and this is here very nice
and final touch how many pages yeah it's
nice to see how causal could wrote this
now we just place a 1 queen and gets the
rope to take and then King H form and he
will win the H point now yes against
this and sorry hey this of course you
play h5 and there's nothing that white
can do now you're going to take this
pawn and if you do this then okay what
it's not going to save a chance at the
end rook takes a train going to happen
so a win by the world champion in this
game and it was a tough one he really
had a bad position and somehow managed
to not lose immediately and then alien
up somehow fell apart in the time
control yeah maybe the results that they
had before also played a role in there
sometimes cases where you simply cannot
play against someone area you simply are
not comfortable in some way of course
Carl is the better player compared to
iron off but he still should win like
all games so the for the final round we
have a rest day so eating the event and
trailing arms and if I he have a point
aronian have a point and cows would have
a point so it's good possible that we
have a joint winner
loyalty I think it's unlikely that the
old role but we'll see we'll see what
happens going to have an interesting
final round yeah thanks for watching the
car would share for the penultimate
round I'll be back with covering and the
final round soonish bye bye
[Music]